[Music]
if you want to understand why as
weddings across America and the world
this year thousands probably millions of
people will be lunging their pinky
fingers over their heads you have to go
back to 1967 67 what the year that James
Brown recorded a song called cold sweat
a watershed moment in the history of
music because it assured in the era of
funk now of course you could go back
earlier than that music styles are
always being born out of what came
before but James Brown in the 1960s was
funk and cold sweat is the record where
he first solidified this new sound
what makes cold sweat so funky is that
all of the instruments making it up work
toward enhancing the rhythm gone are the
melodic chord progressions of R&B and
soul which mark Browns earlier career
everything in cold sweat the guitars the
horns the face you can brown voice were
used like drums you can hear it the
harmonics are static the rhythm is
everything and the drums themselves are
doing something even more interesting I
just I play back 50 mm of that Clyde
Stubblefield drummer for James Brown and
probably the most influential musician
of the 20th century that you've never
heard of the drumbeat from cold sweat
takes the classic 4/4 beat of popular
music which sounds like this and adds
syncopation or unexpected emphasis at
different moments that make it sound
more like this
[Music]
this signature syncopation of Clyde
Stubblefield define the sound of funk
for decades to come but it had a far
greater impact than that this drum solo
you're hearing right now from a 1968
live performance is the most sampled
beat in the history of music appearing
in over 1300 tracks including these
cometh right on the ground a young [ __ ]
got in the back of a play Bob Lakes de
Sade there's a reason double fields
drumming and the cadence of funk is so
danceable the study out of Denmark in
2014 showed that people were most likely
to want to dance when the rhythm of a
song he was moderately syncopated to
uniform and it can get boring to complex
like jazz music for example and people
can't keep up the rhythmic complexity of
funk hip hop which is an outgrowth of
funk and TDM is just enough that your
brain wants to fill in the gap with
dancing in other words
funk music is in the Goldilocks zone for
making people wanna move you can draw a
straight line from cold sweat to Bruno
Mars's 24-karat magic it inherits and
refines the same lessons that James
Brown learned exactly 50 years ago just
listen to the syncopation in the
drumbeat 24-karat magic is essentially
made up of that drum plus a number of
synthesizers that play the role of
guitar bass and horn sections from
Browns music they have the same
percussive quality the signature of funk
here
to me Bruno Mars is a vessel on 24-karat
magic is a time mission it travels back
to James Brown but it makes some
important stops in the history of funk
along the way
no secrets that Mars is pulling most
aggressively from the early 1980s an era
that many see is marking the decline of
funk music before its major resurgence
in the samples of hip hop a few years
later by 1980 Sly Stone Bootsy Collins
and George Clinton had largely finished
taking funk on its cosmic trip across
the universe but the sounds of 24-karat
magic come right out of the 80s when
funk came back to earth sort of and
fully embrace the synthesizer
everybody knows rich in okay is a hell
of a drug but there are a lot of great
acts that have been largely forgotten by
pop culture like Midnight Star those
high-pitched simplex sound familiar
[Music]
there are other great groups from this
period like cameo and the gap band but
for my money the artist Mars is most
indebted to here is Roger Troutman every
time I would use the voice box people
will be dancing until I use until it and
when I started using they would look up
like never seem to hypnotize them in a
way yes it really works watch this
ladies and gentlemen you're watching
video show oh ha ha ha this vocoder part
at the beginning of 24-karat magic is a
direct nod to Troutman in his band zap
he took the voice box further
artistically than any other artist
[Music]
roger troutman was at the babies
electro-funk using the same repertoire
of glittering shining synthesizers that
give 24 karat magic all this color this
is what Bruno Mars and its producers
have done they've channeled a long
tradition in the instruments and the
beats and the energy of this music a
part of that tradition is iconic part of
it is forgotten but the good news is
that 24-carat magic doesn't discriminate
it remembers the complete history and
hopefully when you're dancing to it at
parties this year you do too I love funk
music so much that was so much fun to
make thank you guys for watching that
there's a new nerdwriter video every
Wednesday so if you click that box right
over there
you can get more videos like this thank
you for that and thank you to birth for
sponsoring this video
Verve is a great service that pulls
together a lot of great content channels
like crunchyroll Funimation roosterteeth
tested mondo cartoon hangover pretty
cool that crunchyroll and Funimation
part in the same place by the way you
can download the Verve app on your
PlayStation Xbox iOS or Android and if
you get the VirB combo pack at this link
you can get a seven day free trial and
once you get that combo pack I'd
recommend that you watch Hunter x Hunter
which is a shown end battle anime that
kind of deconstruct that genre really
cool also untested Adam Savage's one day
build is awesome the guy for Mythbusters
really really cool all the shows are in
HD and ad-free definitely recommend
checking out the bros app thank you guys
so much again for watching me indulge my
love of funk music Oh see you all oh oh
I got this [ __ ] who was heavier
than I thought thank you